it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we expose the stories
behind the headlines for that we turn to
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond Biden met his match on
Saturday
well that's one way to put a judge look
for the first time Biden seemed like the
coherent one this is Senator John
fetterman who may have commented on the
president's state of being
and now I'm standing next to the
president again next to a collapsed
Bridge here this is a president that is
committed to infrastructure yeah and
then on top of that the the jewel
kind of a
law of the information
uh bill that is going to make sure that
there's going to be Bridges all across
like this all across the America getting
rebuilt okay now I got to say one thing
before you talk he said he was
absolutely right he said he was standing
next to a collapsed Bridge made sense to
me
exactly look the one that needs
rebuilding here judge is fetterman I
mean look if the Kennedy Center ever
revives Young Frankenstein we've got the
man for him and look fetterman couldn't
even properly introduce a friend that's
sad it's a pleasure to be here and to
introduce my my friend Congressman Boyle
bile well thank you I'm uh Congressman
Brendan Boyle
well I guess Boyle bile is closed judge
one out of two ain't bad well Raymond
today Biden sounded like he caught
whatever fetterman has
oh it's nice to be here as you said
working on something that's
positive thing going forward and not
fixing something that happened very well
very badly the reason I'm optimistic is
because of this generation they're in
they're in I've committed that by 2020
we will have conserved 30 percent of all
the lands and Waters the United States
as jurisdiction over what does that mean
they will have conserved over 30 percent
of the land over which the United States
has jurisdiction does that mean we're
selling it all to China
with judge he said he promises to do it
by 2020. somebody tell it should tell
them it's already 20 23. but this is
this climate boondoggle he set aside 10
billion dollars for something called the
Biden civilian climate Corps they do
what nature did to all these conserved
territories God help us yeah got to help
us is right now the White House Press
Secretary is reveling in her status her
historic status
this is a historic Administration I'm a
historic figure and I certainly walk in
history every day but this is also a
historic making administration because
of this president
yeah yeah it's historic the way the
Hindenburg and the Titanic were historic
judge anything is historic if you frame
it properly I mean we're historic it's
the first time we're together at 10 40
on Juneteenth I mean uh but the Biden
historical society never ends kjp is not
the only historic figure there
second gentlemen oh those dad jokes and
we're gonna do it here why did the
political reporter go to the gym so
often
[Music]
that's clever
ah it sounds like his wife
these these two these two better stick
to being historical because hysterical
they ain't I can tell you look before we
go judge I have to update you on your
favorite Royals Harry and Megan yeah
yeah well I know you follow their every
exploit uh you know they lost that 20
million dollar Spotify deal Bill Simmons
who is a Spotify executive put it this
way
I wish I had been involved in the Megan
and Harry leave Spotify negotiation
rifters that's the podcast we should
have launched with them
judge Megan didn't even do her own
podcast her staff would reportedly
interview the people she invited on and
she would overdub the questions later we
need to sign up for that gig that would
be like you know you get your assistance
to assistant to do the interview and
then you just fake the questions later
there are a couple of words for that
fraudulence is one the other could be
called the Sussex solution well you know
what's crazy about it now they say that
uh she there's reports that she may be
the model for Dior I mean I don't know
where they get this but uh oh it's right
yeah that through uh though Dior shot
down those rumors tonight listen I don't
know if Dior listens to me but I buy
Dior sometimes I think it's very
important they know that that's that's
not making sense to me
well you know deal was trying to do a
deal with both Harry and Megan and look
this is a bit of a Pity I'm sorry
they're not doing it judge because who
better than Meghan Markle to front a
perfume like poison I mean come on and
maybe the two of them could have
launched their own new fragrance lazy
and Untitled it smells like old cash
with a hint of Oprah well that's very
good appealing to something yeah I'll
tell you the two of them I don't think
they figured out what it is they need to
do you know other than hate the Royals
and every time I look at Kate she said
she looks so perfect she's everything
about her is perfect and I think this
one's just dying that she's not over
there but they could have stayed and
they made a choice not to you know well
you can't gripe about the relatives and
that'd be your whole brand people get
tired of it and after that they say okay
what are you going to do now the answer
for these two not much well you got to
give him credit how do you make 20
million dollars uh you know as they call
them Drifters uh on a podcast that you
only do 12 on I don't even want to
divide that up you know no it's
unbelievable yeah I mean my gosh you you
do more shows than that in two weeks I
mean give me a break
that's unbelievable Raymond we love you
take care love you too Jeff all right
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else